the second lesson is quite short
and introduces the most common ways of
greeting people kamasava and kamatalivu
one is formal one is not so formal
if we look at kamasava
the first thing to realize is that sa is
just
a contraction of
is simply how
is it going
which is normally used with people that
we already know quite well
notice that it's coma we don't pronounce
the t
however as we saw in the previous lesson
when we say come on vu
we're really asking how
are you going
and here we do pronounce the t because
it's followed by a vowel
now we get our first look at the past
tense in french
and the phrase in the lesson said atu
weekend
so we see that it's like have you spent
a good weekend it's very similar the
word order is very similar to english
have you
passed or spent a good weekend and the
answer is
so uh with all these verbs that we've
highlighted here in orange
you will have to learn how they change
and the different forms
and fortunately more and more
dictionaries
on the web
offer conjugations or you can google for
conjugations of these different verbs
that should be enough to get you started
the most important thing is to listen
over and over again to the lesson to
save a lot of words and phrases to your
database for review in your flashcards